college is expensive like really
expensive especially here in the United
States of guns fast food and student
debt it wasn't always this way
in 1980 the average cost of tuition for
one year at a four-year private college
was $3500 adjusted for inflation that's
ten thousand two hundred twenty sixteen
dollars today that senior of college
goes for thirty two thousand dollars
three times as much as only thirty six
years ago so what's behind this well
that's both a complicated and
controversial question to understand why
college has risen in cost we first have
to understand why college has always
been expensive the biggest fraction of
your tuition goes to salaries the
national average student of faculty
ratio is 18 to 1 meaning that for every
18 students there's one faculty member
the average professor at a private
college makes one hundred and twenty six
thousand nine hundred and eighty-one
dollars per year divided by eighteen
that comes out to only seven thousand
and fifty four dollars which doesn't
seem that bad but you have to consider
that there's more than just faculty
there's also coaches and gardeners and
kitchen staff and dorm staff and
maintenance people and admission staff
and marketers and IT staff and security
guards and college presidents all
together the salaries and benefits of
all these individuals add up to a
whopping 24,000 dollars of our $32,000
tuition salaries tend to be high because
College functions similarly to many
other industries following the rules of
supply and demand the most popular
college majors vary over time because
interests change to reflect changes in
culture the problem is you can't just
magically create new professors by the
time new professors go through their 20
years of education and specialize in a
field the major will no longer be the
popular one so when a major is popular
colleges have to compete to get
professors and the only thing that
really matters is money money brings
more professors more professors bring
more students and more students bring
more money at the same time professors
in historically popular majors received
tenure tenure is the idea that in order
to promote academic freedom long time
professors should have their job
guaranteed until retirement with
professors that legally cannot be let go
there can often be an abundance of
professors in less popular study areas
so we still have eight thousand dollars
of tuition on account of
or colleges need places to teach and
their infrastructure is rather
unnaturally expensive classes only run
for eight or ten hours a day five days a
week for 40 or so weeks a year that
means that classrooms are only in use
23% of the time the college still has to
pay for the space the other 77% of the
time which of course adds up
additionally colleges really like to
build nice buildings because these
tracks students the average cost to
build a building varies by location but
a verge is between 115 dollars and two
hundred fifteen dollars per square foot
by contrast UMass Amherst Commonwealth
Honors College cost three hundred and
fifty four dollars per square foot UMass
Boston's general academic building
number one costs five hundred ninety
four dollars per square foot and
Berkeley's lower Sproul building cost
six hundred and fifty four dollars per
square foot of course there are other
factors contributing to the high price
of college but staffing and buildings
are the big two now for the reason
College has tripled in price it's always
been expensive to pay highly educated
people to teach an inefficiently used
buildings so what has changed in the
last thirty years well college is more
popular than ever in the last 20 years
college enrollment has increased by 50
percent federal and state funding for
colleges has actually increased to an
all-time high since 1980 but with the
simultaneous increase in students per
student funding has hit an all-time low
in 1990 Ohio's flagship public
university Ohio State University pay for
25 percent of their budget with
government money 1 2012 only 7% of their
budget was paid for by the state with
less federal and state money students
have to pay more out-of-pocket to make
up the difference
additionally colleges have changed to
appeal to the Millennial Generation
according to William Strauss and Neil
Howe the millennial generation born
between 1982 and 2004 are characterized
by seven core traits they are sheltered
confident team oriented conventional
pressured achieving and they feel
special sometimes called trophy kids
Millennials tend to be more ambitious
and more unique than the preceding
generation which means that they tend to
believe more in the right fit idea for
college colleges respond to this
attitude by adding more and more
amenities to help them stand out to the
growing number of students all these new
amenities required more
more management which contributed to the
boom in administration at universities
according to the US Department of
Education the number of administrator
positions increased 60% between 1993 and
2009 which is 10 times faster than the
number of tenured professor positions so
just as I finished my why flying is so
expensive video by telling you that
flying is not that expensive
I'll finish this video by telling you
that college is not that expensive
85% of full-time degree-seeking students
at four-year universities receive some
sort of financial aid with the average
grant hovering at around fifteen
thousand five hundred dollars that's a
significant amount but I'll admit that
there's still a significant amount left
over until you consider that going to
college is the single greatest
investment you can make in your life
especially today people who go to
college earn on average 98 percent more
than those who only have a high school
diploma and that number is up from only
40 percent 35 years ago so given that
what's the true cost of college when you
look at it holistically over your whole
life the cost of going to college is not
$32,000 a year or 128 thousand dollars
over four years but rather negative five
hundred thousand dollars by skipping the
opportunity to go to college you will
forfeit on average half a million
dollars in potential earnings go to
college kids thank you for watching I'm
very excited to say the first time ever
this video is sponsored by audible.com
audible is a company that I admire a lot
and have used for years before the
sponsorship as I imagine any subscriber
of Wendover Productions does too
I love learning and a great way to learn
is through reading books the problem is
I live a busy life and rarely have time
to sit down and read a book instead
I fit reading into my schedule by
listening to books when driving doing
dishes running whenever audible has an
amazing selection of 250,000 titles
including one of the best non-fiction
books of all time and a personal
favorite of mine Freakonomics which can
be yours for free forever by signing up
for a 30-day free trial using the link
ww audible calm wind / alternatively you
can download any other book for free
with that free trial using that link to
sign up for a free trial is the
single biggest way you can help support
wine over productions so I do hope you
consider it aside from that you can
subscribe to this channel if you haven't
already by clicking the button here or
follow me on Twitter app whenever pro
you can also check out last week's video
on Dagon H the day sweet and switch
driving directions here thank you again
and I'll see you soon for another
Wendover productions video